bonjour dans trois semaines le dimanche
22 mars précisément aura lieu le premier
tour des élections départementales un
scrutin à deux tours qui été réformés
puisque vous désignerez désormais des
binômes un homme une femme c'est la loi
sur la parité
ces binômes seront élus pour une période
de six ans sur des cantons plus grands à
l'occasion de ces élections france 3
basse normandie ouest france et france
bleu vous propose trois débats sur les
trois départements bas-normands premier
débat aujourd'hui consacré au
département de la manche j'ai à mes
côtés sébastien berio journaliste à
france bleu cotentin bonjour sébastien
jean franck bonjour à tous et christian
le rosier directeur départemental de
ouest france dans la manche
bonjour christian bonjour francs bonjour
à tous coups de projecteurs aujourd'hui
sur ce département de la manche qui va
passer donc de 52 à 27 cantons le nombre
de cantons on vous le savez a été divisé
par deux objectif rééquilibrer les
choses entre ville et campagne avec des
tailles moyennes de cantons situés
autour de 18 mille habitants
quelles priorités pour la manche quels
enjeux politiques ou encore qui
succédera à jean françois legrand qui
était à la tête de ce département depuis
17 ans peut-être à nos invités que nous
accueillons sur son plateau et qui vont
débattre dans un instant philippe bas
pour l'ump
bonjour pour peut dire que l'on vous
êtes le favori un des sondages pour
succéder à jean françois legrand pire
billet vous représenter le parti
socialiste cette conseiller général
sortant bonjour bonjour jean jacques
noëls candidats et secrétaire
départemental du front national dans la
manche bonjour bonjour et ralph lejamtel
vous défendez les couleurs du front de
gauche et vous êtes candidat dans le
nord cotentin
bonjour toujours chaunu nous
accompagnent bonjour chaunu bonjour
france vous aurez le premier mot moi oui
alors que serait la france sans le
département de la manche département
qu'à une forme si particulière et moi
j'ai envie de dire et que serait le
conseil général sans jean françois
legault
c'est un personnage atypique un mouton à
cinq pattes il est moulé à la louche sur
ce département il il a un côté gaulliste
il a un côté chiraquien j'ai fait une
tête de veau et puis c'est un écologiste
en fait c'est un humaniste qui va le
remplacer ça va être compliqué non et
bien justement question personnelle je
dirais pour commencer qui pour le
remplacer
est ce que vous vous imaginez les uns et
les autres à la place de jean françois
legrand dans un mois je commençais tient
par philippe bas puisque c'est une des
interrogations de cette campagne dans à
moi vous êtes à la place de jean
françois leblanc c'est quelque chose que
vous envisagez vous cette question comme
ça au hasard
je vais répondre bien sûr d'abord bravo
à chaunu comme toujours il a réussi de
quelques traits à brosser le portrait de
notre président de conseil général et je
crois que quel que soit le parti de
notre assemblée mon siège
chacun reconnaît son immense engagement
pour la manche le numérique le
désenclavement routier les énergies
marines renouvelables
aujourd'hui le développement de
l'hydrogène et la solidarité une
solidarité que le département de la
manche a amené un haut niveau mais vous
ne regardez pas tout à fait à ma
question oui mais bien parce que c'est
c'est vrai que je viens en aura-t-on
tous les villages de l'histoire je n'ai
pas eu envie d'y répondre sans rebondir
dans l'ordre que vous aviez vous même
choisi en parlant un instant de jean
françois legrand pour lui rendre hommage
alors je me prépare je n'en fait pas
mystère mais les élections
départementales c'est pas tout à fait
une élection municipale s'est pas
exactement une liste avec son chef de
file
et donc je me suis rendu disponible nous
avons une équipe de manche elle est
profondément renouvelée nous imaginons
avec la féminisation qu'il y aura à peu
près deux tiers de nouveau dans
l'assemblée départementale
oui c'est ça entre 65 et 70% nous avons
un bilan un projet
et je me suis proposé pour animer cette
campagne je serai disponible si mes
collègues le souhaite et si je suis élu
ça fait beaucoup de si
ces matériaux de france bleu cotentin
est-ce qu'ils sont déjà répartis les
rôles parce qu'il ya d'autres noms
parlent aussi de françois brière le
maire de saint lô qui pourrait jouer un
rôle important
vous avez déjà dit qui fera quoi écoutez
nous n'avons pas l'habitude de préjuger
de la décision des électeurs ce qui est
exact c'est que nous avons beaucoup de
compétences beaucoup de personnalités
certaines déjà très expérimenté dans
l'assemblée françois brière en fait
partie n'est pas le seul et nous voulons
agir en équipe
alors on va essayer de respecter le
temps de parole même si ce ne sera pas à
la seconde mais pour qu'il y ait une
équité entre les différents intervenants
puisqu'on était sur cette question de la
succession de jean françois le grand et
que c'est vrai qu'on en a beaucoup parlé
à la presse je m'adressais aux trois
autres candidats pierre billet je vais
poser la même question au cafi liban
demain vous imaginez à la tête de ce
département
côté philippe bas raison je vous rejoins
sur ce point là c'est qu'avant de se
distribuer les postes
il faut aller affronter les électeurs
parce que ce sont eux qui vont décider
qui sera en situation dans un mois
d'être le président du conseil général
la succession bien sûr ouvert puisque
jean-françois annoncé qu'il ne se
représentait pas au delà de différences
politiques je les dis d'ailleurs je vais
leur dire j'ai du respect de la
sympathie pour l'homme
j'ai des désaccords avec lui notamment
sur la politique sociale qui est menée
actuellement par par philippe bas c'est
ce qui est un peu la ligne de
démarcation entre la majorité et
l'opposition au conseil général
concernant les candidatures de philippe
bas ou d'autres jeux j'avais bien
compris que philippe bas et était dans
les starting blocks j'avais cru
comprendre aussi que marc lefèvre était
en embuscade lui aussi je pense que tout
ça c'est des scénarios puisqu'il est
christian le rosier de ouest france
mardi dernier lors de la dernière
session du conseil général de la manche
finalement l'hommage le plus vibrant à
jean françois le grand
c'est le groupe de l'opo
ici on est de la gauche qui lui a rendu
en session publique
est ce que ça veut dire que demain après
ces élections même si vous n'êtes pas à
la majorité de ce département est ce que
vous imaginez pouvoir travailler aussi
facilement avec un nouveau président
divers droite ou de droite ou conseil de
la manche jean françois le grand c'est
jean françois le grand et si on lui a
rendu hommage avant tout un hommage à sa
à sa personne à l'humaniste ce qu'il est
nous nous sommes dans l'opposition au
conseil général
nous allons nous présenter aux élections
et puis le soir des élections mais on
fera les contres et on verra si on est
en situation de pouvoir revendiquer ou
ne pas revendiquer la présidence du
conseil général et voir tout état de
cause il y aura un candidat qui
représente ma sensibilité à la
présidence du conseil général mais quels
sont vos objectifs pierre billes et à
gauche en sachant qu' un contexte
national difficile pour vous que la
manche n'est pas un département de
gauche par tradition quels sont vos
objectifs là pour ce scrutin de locatif
c'est de se faire élire dans un maximum
de cantons j'ai bien conscience que le
contexte national ne plaide pas en notre
faveur
j'ai bien conscience aussi qu'on est
dans une élection de terrain où va voter
pour des hommes plus que sur des enjeux
nationaux
on va en parler dans quelques instants
j'aimerais simplement qu'on termine
notre tour de table comme promis un sur
ce qui va se passer là dans quelques
semaines
la succession de jean-françois legrand
rafle chatel il ya eu sur ce plateau
quelquefois des échauffourées avec jean
françois le grand
vous disiez en préparant cette émission
la meilleure décision qu'il est prise
durant ses 17 ans de mandat c'est
quitter l'ump
oui c'était c'était une décision qui
était qui était courageuse à l'époque et
j'avais eu l'occasion de lui dire ce que
monsieur legrand a dit dernièrement et
que je partage c'est qui le souhaitent
des élus qu'ils soient courageux et qui
ont le sens de l'intérêt général
c'est ce qu'il a dit donc je me suis
demandé si ça s'adressait pas aux
candidats du front de gauche venant de
sa peur parce que des élus courageux et
qui ont le sens de l'intérêt général
c'est précisément ce que nous serions au
front de gauche
si nous étions en position d'être élu
cabinet dirait il ya quelques instants
que ça a été un bon président avec
lequel il avait pu échanger a eu lui a
rendu hommage
le groupe socialiste lui a rendu hommage
en début de semaine est ce que l'âme du
président en la personne du président
est ce que vous diriez la même chose
non on choisit de noms de vos
antécédents si le saas est la plus
politique qu'il sera pas surpris moi je
pense qu'il ya eu quand même deux choses
qui n'ont pas fonctionné dans les dix
dernières années c'est les emprunts
toxiques qui quand même mettre la
collectivité territoriale dans une
grande difficulté
ces fameux emprunts toxiques sur le
franc suisse d'autre part la politique
d'insertion de monsieur bah est en effet
un échec
peut être qu'on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir les budgets qui sont alloués à
cette insertion sont en chute libre donc
d'un point de vue politique il ya un
autre problème c'est la fameuse gratuité
de la demi-pension que monsieur legrand
avait remis en cause il ya quelques
années donc c'est un homme sympathique
qui est plein d'initiatives certes mais
d'un point de vue politique la
différence entre le front de gauche et
monsieur legrand n'échappera ce qui
explique les quelques classes qu'on a pu
voir ces dernières années je vais poser
la question maintenant pour terminer
notre tour de table à jean jacques
thorel pour le front national
simplement un homme qui est s'en va il
laisse un département et vous brillez
7,7
présidence le travail de jean françois
leblanc moi je me vois puisque le la
dynamique du front national et est
importante dans la manche où nous sommes
sortis vous y voyez oui bien sûr nous
sommes sortis en tête dans 71% des
communes du département aux élections
européennes nous sommes le seul parti à
présenter des candidats dans tous les
cantons
et moi je me vois bien été à la tête du
département oui pour accompagner la
victoire de marine le pen en 2017
et maintenant un département géré par le
front national n'en mangerai pas le
front national alors écouter celle
inverse de ce qui a été fait pour
l'instant le moi j'ai pas j'ai pas
constater je viens je veux bien entendre
que monsieur legrand est quelqu'un de
tout à fait sympathique et agréable je
le connais pas mais par contre ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'il n'y a pas eu de
miracle économique jean-françois legrand
de la manche
la manche est à l'image du pays peu de
développement industriel des usines qui
ferment un peu partout nous sommes les
parents pauvres du réseau ferré en
normandie et dans l'ouest
voilà moi je n'ai pas constaté vraiment
de de politiques efficaces en matière
d'emploi en matière sociale voilà pour
moi c'est de son bilan est plutôt
négatif
alors on va parler des enjeux politiques
dans un instant je mets d'abord sur la
rnt de pierre delye mba s'il vous plaît
parce que philippe bas n'ont donc il
sera éventuellement candidat pour
succéder à jean-françois là je veux une
pose une question on sait tous qu'en
2017 qui à la loi sur le cumul des
mandats qui va se mettre en place et que
monsieur bah ne pourra pas donc pas
tendent à diriger le département plus
que deux ans alors quel choix fera t-il
abandonna fils le sénat abandonnera-t-il
conseil départemental c'est le conseil
départemental ça va nécessiter beaucoup
de travail c'est une nouvelle
gouvernance qu'il va falloir mettre en
place c'est vrai que ce conseil
départemental va avoir besoin d'un
président qui s'installe et qui
s'installe pour six ans en clair vous
dit à philippe bas c'est soit il est
sénateur les restes le sénateur soit il
vient à temps choisi un département
réponse de philippe bas bon je vais
essayer d'obéir aux injonctions nouveau
monde voisins ça me permettra aussi
d'apporter des éléments de réponse à ce
que le fn fg pu déclarer reparle du mps
je m'étais que j'ai passé les amalgames
parfois ça peut être un peu la porte de
monsieur bah de dire front national le
front de gauche je la trouve que c'est
tout à fait déplacée oui parce que il ya
l'exemple histoire du foot non non moi
je ne suis pas du tout à un anti système
je suis élu suédois non mais peut-être
que vous êtes mal peut-être que nous
allons prendre
non juste monsieur billets non mais là
alesi monsieur jamais la juste et je
vous laisserai finir je trouve que c'est
très venimeuse que vous venez de dire
moi je suis élu je suis élu au conseil
de la communauté urbaine de cherbourg
je suis élu de cherbourg donc je ne me
définis pas comme un anti système
d'autre part le parallèle que vous
faites entre le front de gauche et le
front national est tout à fait déplacée
dans l'histoire de la république
française nous nous avons toujours
défendu la république
nous avons toujours été du côté de la
république le front national a toujours
combattu la république
donc si vous ne faites pas cette
différence est bel et bien terminée à
poser une question est ce que vous aviez
fait revivre le jeu du 29 mars
et puis que calais vous annoncez
justement si vous êtes résident du
nucléaire est-ce que vous pouvez nous
apporter des éléments de réponse sur les
emprunts toxiques qui coûte 7 millions
de chats tachetés contribuables en mai
parce que fax et si je vais être très
calme et s'il n'y avait pas eu une
attaque si venimeuse de monsieur bah je
l'aurais laissé parler mais le parallèle
entre le front national et le front de
gauche
je pense que pour un futur président du
conseil général de la manche ou
peut-être futur président je pense qu'il
part très mal alors on va pas refaire le
débat
j'aimerais qu'on aille je vais répondre
chaque chose en son temps
répondez s'ils voulaient bien philippe
bas si la bille et qui vous demande ce
que vous ferez dans le cadre du non
cumul des mandats puisque ce sera une
obligation en 2010 est très bien tout
d'abord je veux dire que il ya
effectivement les familles politiques
qui se situe dans le cadre d'une
alternance entre forces du gouvernement
et il ya des forces politiques qui sont
différentes les unes des autres
je conviens que j'en conviens mais dont
le projet est un projet de remise en
cause du système
c'est par un raccourci ce que j'ai dit
résidera que ferez vous s'agissant
maintenant de la question du cumul de
mandats je considère pour ma part qu'il
est préférable que les élus nationaux
est une responsabilité locale
j'observe d'ailleurs que quand bernard
cazeneuve était député et maire de
cherbourg
personne ne disait qu'il était un
mauvais mer ou qu'il était un mauvais
députés en réalité une loi monsieur voit
sur la vidéo est en réalité je crois que
c'est non seulement possible mais c'est
également utile d'ici 2017
il ne vous échappe pas qu'il y à
d'autres échéances qui se profilent
j'espère pour ma part que on rétablira
ce qui est de mon point de vue de bon
sens c'est-à-dire la possibilité de
concilier le national et le local c'est
bon pour le national mais c'est bon
aussi pour le look en 2017 il y aurait
effectivement cette élection
présidentielle et peut-être des choses
qui changeront alors on va faire avancer
ce débat avant de ne parler des enjeux
politiques ont révoqué l'actualité avec
ses grosses inquiétudes aux abattoirs
industriels de la manche les ayem qui
emploie 600 personnes dont 400 sur le
site de sainte cécile près de villedieu
cette semaine et salariés en planter
quelques 500 croix devant le siège de la
coopérative
porcine cap 50 près de saint lô cap 50
c'est le principal actionnaire des ayem
que dites-vous celui dit aux salariés
qui se demande si dans quatre mois à
l'issue du délai d'observation à l'issue
de ce redressement judiciaire se
demandent s'ils vont garder leur emploi
je m'adressais à jean jacques noël mais
j'espère pour eux déjà qui aura un
repreneur sérieux qui va se manifester
mais le drame des abattoirs ayem c'est
avant tout et là vous parliez d'un
amalgame tout à l'heure la
responsabilité de l'ump et du ps
ce que vous aviez lu mps voilà ce sont
même si ces gens là au niveau local vont
faire pleurer margot soutenir les futurs
licenciés
ils sont comme responsable de la
politique qui a été mise en place des
abattoirs ayem qui sont rentrés en
concurrence déloyale avec l'allemagne
qui truste l'abattage et la
transformation de premier rang au niveau
de la viande c'est l'allemagne profite
en plus de la directive travailleurs
détachés de l'union européenne et
embauchent des polonais à bas coûts on
ne peut pas faire face alors on l'a vu
avec gad en bretagne on le voit avec
ayem dans la manche on ne peut plus
faire face à l'arrêt ces gens là qui au
niveau local des soutiennent l'abattoir
leur parti les crises il simplement pour
l'égalité que là ce soit le conseil
général de la manche où que ce soit la
région ont mis beaucoup d'argent dans la
balance depuis quelques années
concernant m
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire de plus je ne
viens pas que de l'argent il aurait
fallu mettre en place un système de
coopérative tels que ça existe ailleurs
comme en haute savoie
voilà où je regardais hier la vie
d'annecy qui qui dit qu'ils fabriquent
800 mille repas par an ils vont passer
le cap des un million cette année de
produits locaux
voilà il fallait créer une structure
pour accompagner la restauration
collective dans le département aussi
bien des cantines scolaires des
entreprises créer une structure efficace
et ous avez visionné ont lié aux
prédateurs launay dans ce redressement
judiciaire il faut trouver des solutions
il n'y a pas pour l'instant de repreneur
or le celui qui s'était déclaré pour le
site de sainte cécile a jeté l'épongé la
semaine dernière les réunions notamment
au ministère de l'agriculture
ça fait juste la plus tard que jeudi
dernier sanchez rafle l'hôtel je laisse
la parole dans un instant simplement
pour préciser ce que disait christian le
rosier sur les aides qui ont été
attribués par les collectivités il ya eu
on l'a suivi et ça a été confirmé
quelques 8 millions d'euros qui ont été
proposées aux ayem en janvier 2014 pour
sauver l'entreprise
ralph lejamtel et juste pour compléter
ce que vous dites il me semble que la
réunion d'hier a donné lieu à un
possible repreneur qui n'est pas cité et
j'ai vu que les responsables syndicaux
par rapport à cette table ronde était un
peu plus optimistes alors je suis
prudent laisser ce que j'ai lu dans la
presse nous sur les sur les 8 millions
dont vous venez de parler par rapport à
la société d'économie mixte pour
reprendre les bâtiments on regrette que
cela se soit fait sans contrepartie et
que ça n'ait pas changé
comment dire la stratégie de
l'entreprise parce que les salariés ils
ont quand même eu une attitude qui est
remarquable c'est qu'ils ont travaillé
ils ont maintenu l'outil de travail
et là ils mènent une lutte qui est
également remarquable et on souhaite
vraiment que ça puisse que ça puisse
bien se terminer cette histoire on
propose un pôle public de coopération
qui permettrait une intervention
citoyenne et des salariés sur les
stratégies d'entreprises parce que la
stratégie qui a été suivi par ce groupe
d'ayem est une mauvaise stratégie et les
responsabilités devraient être bien
identifiés pour qu'il y ait des
commentaires des décisions politiques de
prise question de sébastien hinault
cotentin c'est libre à vous qui avez
suivi le dossier de près au conseil
général est ce que vous êtes d'accord
pour dire que le principal responsable
de l'échec de la reprise c'est en tout
cas ce que disent les les salariés et
les syndicats c'est cap 50
la coopérative porcine qui a été trop
exigeante et qui du coup a fait fuir les
repreneurs vous êtes d'accord avec ça
cette façon de voir les choses
je trouve que ce n'est pas notre
problème aujourd'hui notre problème
c'est de savoir comment on peut faire
redémarrer en trouvant un accord qui
précisément à sur la solidarité entre
les producteurs les salariés un
repreneur et les collectivités sont
derrières elles ont d'ailleurs été
unanime
elles ont sauvé l'entreprise une
première fois en août 2013 en mettant
avec la caisse des dépôts et
consignations près de 9 millions d'euros
pour donner de l'argent frais en
rachetant le terrain et les bâtiments
industriels
elles ont voté fin janvier aujourd'hui
régions et départements ça c'est tout ce
qu'il s'est passé j'ai aussi l'art
verizon se fait aujourd'hui il ya eu
comme chacun le sait des discussions qui
n'ont pas abouti il ya une offre qui a
été retiré et qui était inacceptable
j'ai appelé moi même le gouvernement
comme il l'a fait très efficacement pour
les abattoirs gad de bretagne à prendre
ses responsabilités
je me réjouis de la table ronde qui a eu
lieu hier 4 5 vous avez appelé hossein
nous offre un espoir de débouchés et je
peux vous dire est ce sera la sainte
alliance de tous les élus en faveur de
la solution que les collectivités si
cette solution qui ne peut être qu'un
industriel ne pouvons pas nous en
quelque sorte nationalisé au des votes
au niveau départemental et régional les
les abattoirs
il faut une solution industrielle mais
si elle existe nous serons derrière et
nous ferons tout pour la favoriser
ayem sera-t-il le gars de dormans c'est
souvent ce qu'on a entendu y compris
dans la bouche des salariés
gad qui avait supprimé en bretagne en
2013 huit cents emplois pierre billes et
7000 crainte que vous avez je voudrais
revenir un peu sur ayem par rapport à ce
qu'a dit jeanne mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
sûrement eu un manque de vigilance sur
le regard de la gestion de l'entreprise
une fois que les collectivités se sont
engagées pour sauver m il faut quand
même dire que l'état a été fait le
gouvernement a toujours été très présent
aux côtés du conseil général aux côtés
du côté yeux régional pour accompagner
au travers de la sem imagine le
refinancement de d'ailleurs dans les
faits je dire que la réactivité du
gouvernement sur le dossier et la grc
geleen royal a évoqué une table ronde
elle s'est tenue non pas ici au niveau
départemental mais au niveau ministériel
et leurs difficultés ça dure depuis 2003
monsieur balle rappelé tout à l'heure
donc la réactivité on peut en discuter
aussi l'arrêt d'activité ou à la
situation actuelle
ségolène royal promet ya trois jours une
table ronde elle se tient pas ici depuis
dans la manche
elle se tient au ministère à elle réuni
l'agriculture l'économie le travail
l'économie l'écologie et l'intérieur
ça démontre bien que au delà de l'aide à
apporter à ayem le gouvernement se situe
bien dans une le traitement d'une
situation dans son intégralité sans rien
laisser dans l'aube au niveau
environnemental au niveau de la filière
porcine ya une vraie volonté là du
gouvernement de s'engager à la filière
porcine justement elle est estimée à
2500 emplois
en basse-normandie 400 emplois aux
abattoirs y est mais il ya aussi les
sous traitants qui assure la maintenance
du ciqi les transporteurs il y à tous
ceux qui travaillent autour de la terre
disons les charcutiers cette filière est
elle en danger je vous pose la question
à vous si demain ayem ferme
que fait-on il ya l'élevage également en
danger mais également qu'elle est en
danger
c'est d'ailleurs une des raisons qui
font que nous sommes si inquiet
aujourd'hui et notre inquiétude se
transforme en action les uns et les
autres et en particulier les
collectivités
mais l'implication du gouvernement
aujourd'hui est au fond notre dernière
chance car je suis certain que le
gouvernement si une solution
industrielle peut se nouer a les moyens
de permettre à cette solution de se
réaliser à travers un certain nombre de
leviers dont il dispose
alors s'en suivra on va faire avancer ce
débat puis on suivra justement les
déroulements au cours des prochaines
semaines de ce dossier ayem le nord
cotentin est connu pour être le secteur
le plus nucléarisé du pays du nucléaire
qui emploie plus de 8000 personnes en
basse normandie
qu'en sera-t-il demain lundi soir ce
sont quelques 600 personnes qui étaient
rassemblés à cherbourg il a été question
de l'avenir de l'usiné de retraitement
de déchets nucléaires de la hague
puisque l'on a appris fin janvier que
500 emplois seraient supprimés d'ici
2020 craintes qui se sont je dirais même
amplifié à cette semaine puisque le
groupe a annoncé 5 milliards d'euros de
pertes en 2014
je vous demandais il ya quelques
instants
vous adresser aux salariés d'ayem que
dites-vous maintenant aux salariés
d'areva qui se demandent si là aussi
dense cinq ans ils ne vont pas se
retrouver à pôle emploi je m'adressais à
l écoute et le fait que l'intersyndicale
d'areva tous syndicats confondus fasse
une alerte de cette ampleur à cherbourg
avec 600 personnes en disant qu'il y
avait des questions de sûreté qui était
posée et que les 500 emplois ça se
traduirait par d'autres suppressions
d'emplois dans la sous traitance et des
emplois qui sont induits dans le
commerce
le fait d'entendre que au début du mois
de mars y aura des décisions encore plus
graves qui seront prises donc on est
face à un désastre social
il s'agit quand même de la filière du
nucléaire qui nécessite que l'intérêt
général soit pris en compte donc il ya
des choses très concrètes qui doivent
être demandées à l'état qui doit prendre
ses responsabilités c'est la
renégociation du contrat qui lie lusine
d'areva est comment dire et edf excusez
moi parce que c'est un contrat qui est
fait à perte et qui fait perdre de
l'argent auprès d'areva
il faut que toute la filière du
démantèlement et du retraitement soit
sécurisée et qu'il n'y ait pas de
cession d'actifs comme on nous
l'annoncent et j'ai vu que monsieur
macron disait qu'il n'était pas question
de recapitaliser l'entreprise pour le
moment mais qu'on attendait que les
décisions sociales soient prises
ce n'est pas acceptable quand on voit
l'intérêt stratégique de cette filière
donc lors de cette réunion dont vous
avez parlé il y avait une unité des élus
des citoyens et des salariés
et c'est important maintenant il faut
que l'état prenne ses responsabilités
parce qu'on est sur un an
on est quand même sur une filière qui
est très importante je terminerai en
disant que dans le cadre de la
sidérurgie à florange il n'y a pas eu la
prise de responsabilité de l'état dans
le cadre de l'automobile c'est la même
chose et dans le cadre d' alstom n'y a
pas eu non plus une prise de
responsabilité on espère que sur la
question de la filière du nucléaire des
décisions rapides vont être prises alors
question de sébastien périodes de france
bleu cotentin alors pierre biais ralph
lejamtel disait il faut que l'état
prenne ses responsabilités certains
disent la solution c'est de donner du
capital à d'augmenter le capital d'areva
le gouvernement pour le moment dit non
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
veut attendre pour voir très
certainement moi ce que je voudrais dire
sur ce sujet là c'est que areva paye
aujourd'hui des avances des
investissements à peu aventureux au
niger paye le retard de le père en fille
anglais aussi le retard de père ici à
flamanville et que c'est pas aux
salariés de payer le prix de ses
déconvenues du groupe areva
il ya une japd elle l'a dit je crois ce
que toutes les sensibilités politiques
des élus du quota sont aujourd'hui
derrière les salariés d'areva pour les
soutenir dans leur lutte pour l'emploi
rafiq latta disait qu'il fallait
consolider la filière nucléaire lui
donner des chances pour l'avenir est ce
que vous avez la même lecture les uns
les autres
est ce que le nucléaire a encore de
l'avenir dans le nord cotentin dans dix
quinze vingt ans publié moi je pense que
la prière du nucléaire a toute sa place
aujourd'hui à côté des énergies
renouvelables qui vont se développer et
qui se développe et pour lequel le
conseil général a financé énormément les
projets aux côtés de la région et de la
communauté urbaine de cherbourg
on ne va pas aujourd'hui opposer les
yeux et meurt au nucléaire ce qu'il ne
faudrait pas dans cette opération a
reposé la question sécurisé l'emploi
sera créé pour les mères ne viennent pas
compenser les pertes d'emplois dans le
nucléaire
philippe bas quel que soit le
développement des énergies marines
renouvelables
nous aurons besoin du nucléaire et de
nombreux pays sont dans la même
situation que nous très clair or à
l'échelon mondial
et même si areva a fait il ya quelques
années du temps du de la présidence
d'anne lauvergeon de mauvaises affaires
dont on assume les conséquences
aujourd'hui je considère qu areva est
une très grande entreprise française qui
a de l'avenir pour sortir cas de
l'avenir notamment à l'exportation usine
de la hague est unique au monde
nous avons des technologies uniques au
monde le père est unique au monde et je
considère par conséquent qu'aujourd'hui
il faut franchir ce mauvais cap avec une
entreprise qui a des difficultés mais sa
puissance son avenir
le potentiel de développement qu'elle a
en france et à l'étranger me rendre
confiants il faut dans l'immédiat que la
relation entre edf et areva fasse
l'objet d'une tour de table avec le
gouvernement avec les représentants des
salariés car une partie du problème
tient au fait que les prestations
assurées par l' usine de la hague ne
sont pas suffisamment bien prise en
compte par edf question de christian
ziege célibat sur le rôle de monsieur
bah et monsieur noël pour certaines mais
enchaîné quand vous dites passer ce
mauvais cap
est-ce que c'est justement se délester
pour areva d'un certain nombre
malheureusement de salariés est ce que
c'est ça passait le le cap passé le cap
s'est trouvé les solutions avec edf sous
l'égide du gouvernement sans licencier
pour faire en sorte que les effectifs
soient préserver autant que faire se
peut mais il ya des erreurs en retraite
qui permettent d'absorber le cas échéant
des suppressions d'emplois sans qu'il y
ait de coût social
il ne faut en aucun cas aller au delà de
mai est ce que c'est acceptable de
devoir que carey va donc a décidé de
supprimer 500 postes de travail sur le
site de la hague au cours des cinq
prochaines années
est-ce que c'est acceptable ça selon
vous c'est une perspective dans laquelle
nous ne pouvons pas nous inscrire ça va
parce que c'est parce que vous faites là
vous avez un hôtel non mais c'est bien
de le préciser parce que s'il y a six
lits à une perte de compétences par
rapport à des départs en retraite non
non remplacés ça veut dire que la
transmission des savoir faire va se
faire dans de moins bonnes conditions
donc par rapport à ces questions de
sûreté c'est pas possible il est comment
dire
les économies qui sont prévus d'être
faite c'est ce sont des économies d'un
milliard dans les trois ans qui viennent
c'est colossal
et c'est pas possible et ça donc il ne
peut pas y avoir des économies de cette
ampleur sans qu'il y ait des
conséquences sur la sûreté donc j'attire
quand même l'attention des spectateurs
sur ce point on ne peut pas les éditeurs
puisque nous sommes rien
quant à la vente de ces super spectacle
justement voilà quant à la vente de
cession mais moi je me donne pas en
spectacle
quant à la vente de ce nom sur moi non
plus quant à la vente de cession ça a
été le cas dans le cadre de la vente de
riz ware qui était sur l'informatique et
on ne connaît pas le coût de vente sa
tête était une vente à perte donc ça ne
règle pas la question de la trésorerie
va écouter jean jacques noël pour le
front national
on a commencé à entamer le débat entre
nucléaire et énergies marines
renouvelables l'avenir du cotentin
justement vous pour le front national
vous le voyez comment alors il faut
aussi rappeler que areva
est-ce que vous suivez simplement comme
philippe bas il faut pas opposer les
deux non non aux coupes du tout mais il
faut rappeler aussi que personne ne
pouvait prévoir fukushima qui a annulé
une certaine incertain une quantité de
ppr qui devaient être vendus à travers
le monde qui a plombé le cours de
l'uranium qui a fait que
l'investissement la grameen était était
et est moins rentable que prévu
nous nous pensons front national que
l'état doit intervenir
areva
est un fleuron de l'industrie française
ça nous garantit aussi une indépendance
énergétique une souveraineté énergétique
nous nous pensons que nous devons créer
un pôle une synergie entre edf et areva
justement pour garantir cette
indépendance et cette souveraineté
énergétique
bien sûr il faut maintenir les emplois
puisque bon ben may mais sa pratique
jamais employa jugé l'enjeu pour le pour
garantir le maintien des compétences et
l'état doit surtout intervenir puisque
nous l'avons bien fait pour les banques
l'état est intervenu pour sauver les
banques ont leur après on à prêter de
l'argent aux banques ils ont remboursé
une fois que la situation s'était
améliorée
pourquoi ne pas le faire pour nos
industries pourquoi ne pas le faire pour
areva
alors le comportement de la manche
deviendrait date il demain un pôle
d'excellence des énergies marines
renouvelables
c'est une question qui est posée cet
état un souhait de jean françois legrand
qui rêvait d'un projet identique à celui
de toulouse dans l'aéronautique pour
parler de ce qui a été annoncé il y a
quelques années maintenant c'est la
construction de deux usines d'éoliennes
une demain est une autre de pâles sur le
port de cherbourg
on parle aussi de construire des
hydroliennes pour les mettre dans le raz
blanchard ce grand pôle d'excellence des
énergies marines renouvelables est ce
que c'est quelque chose qu'on pourra
toucher du doigt un moment à un autre
filet bas c'est réalisable et de rêve du
président legrand mais ça n'est déjà
plus un rêve il
il a été porté effectivement par le
conseil général de la manche sous
l'impulsion de jean françois legrand
avec l'aide de la région et nous avons
gagné nous sommes pôle national
le gouvernement nous a confié dans le
cadre d'une procédure d'appel à projets
la réalisation de ce projet si bien que
la manche est véritablement de plus en
plus une terre d'énergie et d'énergies
nouvelles avec toute la gamme des
énergies et maintenant vous avez vu le
développement du moteur à hydrogène de
la transformation d'électricité en
hydrogène qui nous permet vraiment
d'avoir sur tous les points une longueur
d'avancé en france et même à
l'international dans le développement
des énergies nouvelles alors le
département de la manche possède 350 km
de coeur qu'on tirait profit de la mer
l'avenir passera peut-être par la mer
quel avenir justement pour ce
département à l'heure de la construction
de la grande normandie dans moins d'un
an la haute et la basse normandie auront
fusionné déjà est ce que les uns et les
autres vous êtes d'accord pour que
lier cette grande région raaflaub tél
oui alors sur la commune nouvelle qui
est un élément du projet de loi
le président de la communauté urbaine de
cherbourg a lancé le débat et nous nous
demandons une consultation citoyenne sur
ce sujet là parce que ça paraît un
minimum qui est un débat qui soit un
débat thématique et qui soit ponctué par
une consultation citoyenne sur la grande
normandie nous n'avons pas eu l'occasion
de se donner notre avis donc il ya quand
même eu un problème démocrate de ne pas
supporter je pense que c'est pas des
sujets simples où on a une réponse comme
sa clé en main ce sont des sujets qui
doivent donner lieu à des débats qui
soit thématiques moi par exemple sur là
où j'ai un avis est que sur la
communauté urbaine de cherbourg sur les
questions de santé et sur les questions
d'urbanisme
il faudrait mieux que ça se fasse à
l'échelle de l'agglomération fort on
compte si on vous posait la question
non je crois que cette manière est
simplement moi alors je peux dire je
suis un bas normands qui je suis attaché
à mon identité de bas normands donc mais
peut-être que la normandie va permettre
d'avoir des choses qui sont
intéressantes parce que ça sera une plus
grande région mais j'ai peur que la
manche se retrouve un petit peu à
l'écart on va faire un rapide tour de
table question de sébastien berio et
pierre le cotentin pierre bleue en clair
la question c'est la grande normandie
est ce que c'est pas le risque après de
devoir le département département de la
manche
isoler nos secondes dans ce grand
ensemble je suis favorable à cette
réunification des deux normandie
il appartiendra aux élus des territoires
de travailler à ce que les retombées
économiques que l'on peut attendre de
cette optimisation des compétences se
fasse de manière équilibrée au niveau
des territoires je pense qu'aujourd'hui
le rambo v et le président de la région
nicolas
hier c rossignol voilà travaille dans ce
sens là à dire qu'on ne pose pas
aujourd'hui les territoires la bataille
de se dire où est la capitale régionale
selon rendre à l'est de caen rouen non
on va peut-être pas parler de saint lô
cherbourg
oui mais les territoires il faudra
qu'ils soient écoutés et entendus au
niveau de cette normandie réunifiée
hoquette personnellement je crois parce
que économiquement que comment ils
peuvent être entendus est ce que ces
crises ajoute l aborder la thématique
des communes nouvelles et c'est tombé et
matic fermés et deux créés ce qu'on a ce
que ce que benoît arrivent et président
de la guilde commune urbaine de chabou
rappelle le grand cotentin est ce qu'il
faut en arriver là pour peser
effectivement au sein de cette nouvelle
région de cette grande région réunissant
à la haute et la basse normandie il est
évident qu'il va falloir revoir la
configuration de le territoire actuel
quand on voit comment ça s'organise à
quand commence à s'organiser à rouen
comment ça s'organise au havre il faut
il faut réfléchir données notamment de
la manche seul ne suffit pas à rendre
pezénois arriver à poser un débat il est
dans son rôle de président de l'exécutif
de poser ce débat là après on y
réfléchit ensemble les communes
nouvelles c'est la commune nouvelle de
la commune urbaine de cherbourg dont
vous parlez il y en a d'autres qui
peuvent se créer ailleurs je pense qu'il
faut réorganiser très certainement le
territoire dans la plus grande des
concertations avec nos concitoyens et
que ça ne reste pas comme c'est au stade
actuel un débat d lui alors là c'est
calme on avance en ce 17 minutes le
temps passe vite et nous sommes désolés
mais pour évoquer la question
sébastien barriault le disait il ya
quelques instants de la capitale quel
chef lieu
on choisira pour cette grande normandie
c'est une obligation dans cette loi
territoriale jean jacques noël pour le
front national
alors vu de la manche alors que tenta du
nord cotentin de chabot mode tu à
préciser d'abord que au front national
nous sommes pour ce cette réunification
ce sera l'occasion parle beaucoup
d'économie mais aussi d'un renouveau
culturel pour la normandie
je rappelle que c'est une région
historiquement qui étaient les plus
riches de france qui a rayonné
culturellement jusqu'en sicile et c'est
l'occasion pour nous d'un renouveau et
peut-être de faire redécouvrir aux
normands de ce que c'est culturellement
qu'une grande normandie
nous nous avons la chance dans cette
réforme territoriale qu'on nous remette
avec nos frères au normand d'autres
régions n'ont pas eu cette chance là en
france puisque elles vont perdre leur
identité culturelle voix il faut se
réjouir car agen qui dit pour moi la
question de la grande normandie et c'est
le rêve français
je suis âgée j'ai pas j'ai pas une
position et à l'histoire il n'ya qu'une
normandie voilà bon vous vous êtes
manière favorable à cette réforme par
contre c'est sûr il va falloir faire
attention à la représentativité du
département au sein de cette grande
région il faudra des élus fort qui
montent au créneau pour défendre les
intérêts de la manche
maintenant nous au front national nous
nous situions un peu dans une autre
optique que mais que mes adversaires
politiques puisque nous défendons notre
triptyque que celui qui est présenté par
par la réforme territoriale nous sommes
pour une commune puissante qui s'appuie
sur un département et sur un état nation
mes adversaires ce soir
soyez un peu plus clair comme la récente
la commune qui avait il ya des plats
voir des communautés la fin les
communautés de communes des communes
voilà proche du citoyen ensuite un
département et un état-nation eux sont
sur une intercommunalité une région et
l'europe voilà nous nous soutenons alors
culturellement c'est vrai par contre
économique économiquement je suis pas
sûr que la manche s'y retrouve et quelle
doit être la commune forte si on va
nommer la commune la commune proche du
citoyen jusqu'au bout permet la lagune
la commune chef lieu avec des drogués de
cette grande normandie puisque un moment
il n'aura bien désigner une wii hôpital
alors je pense que ça va être une
réponse de normand
il va falloir partager entre rouen et
caen alors peut-être des commissions à
caen et puis comme rouen est la capitale
historique
pourquoi pas lors de l'assemblée juge
finira en capital non moi je défends
qu'en est il faut pas aborder cette
discussion en partant perdant le point
d'arrivée la bonne manière suivante
maintenant le point d'arrivée on va voir
ce qu'il sera mais dans un premier temps
il faut bien avoir en tête que la taille
de la région n'est pas tout ses pouvoirs
sont importants et deuxièmement dans la
grande région
toute une partie est proche du bassin
parisien et dans l'orbité du bassin braz
et parisien nous ne serons jamais une
annexe du bassin parisien mais nous ne
voulons pas devenir les parents pauvres
de la grande normandie et pour ceux ci
nous allons devoir nous battre
d'abord vous ne parlez pas du
département je crois moi en l'avenir du
département comme collectivité de
proximité et comme lieu de pouvoir
centres de pouvoir pour forger des
projets qu'on va ensuite discuté c'est
pas avec la grande partie monsieur bob
risquer de perdre des compétences sur
ses pas et le département vous êtes on
l'a su présenter fortement sur la forme
que vous soutenez résidents de
l'application des lois
j'ai rétabli la victoire au sénat vous
le savez très bien j'ai rétabli avec mes
collègues au sénat la majeure partie
nombreux voire du département et j'ai
l'agréable surprise parce que c'en est
une
d'avoir vu que notamment sur des sujets
aussi importante que la maîtrise des
routes
sept mille 700 km de route dans la
manche l'assemblée nationale contre le
projet du gouvernement a voté
majoritairement pour le maintien des
routes dans les départements je crois
que c'est très important
alors ça veut dire que maintenant le
rendent le sénat et l'assemblée étant
d'accord ce sera maintenant inscrit dans
la loi et je crois effectivement que
l'organisation de sélection
départementale à un moment vous ne savez
même pas ce que les élus départementaux
allait faire est en train petit à petit
se clarifier un peu on voit que le
département va garder tout ce qui relève
de la solidarité des contrats de
territoire avec les intercommunalités
mais aussi les collèges et les routes
j'espère les transports scolaires et
nous aurons une collectivité forte dans
la région pour faire contrepoids à
d'autres parties de la région qui n'ont
pas besoin d'équipement puisqu'elles ont
les équipements du bassin paris
situé monsieur pas des gens nos
positions du derby notamment au reste de
la région
non ça qu'on voit les chemins force
vis-à-vis de la région qui a déjà payé
mais ça fait déjà dans les invités dans
une opposition on est dans une
complémentarité monsieur pas vraiment
arrêtée à ce que vous écrivez du club
mais c'est une volonté surtout vouloir
poser les départements sur les jo c'est
une mauvaise manière de commencer ce
débat sur la sur leur normandie
réunifiée
vous avez tort de nous caricaturer je
n'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit que les projets
qui émergeront dans le département de la
manche devront être défendus au niveau
régional dans une région dont il faudra
équilibrer les différents projets pour
que le déséquilibre enfin veut enfin 336
gradins conçu nazis régionaux qui vont
être à lui à la fin de l'année et qui
devront eux aussi porter leur territoire
à la région notamment ceux qui seront
élus dans la manche
est ce qu'il ya un risque que ce
département de la manche
demain deviennent c'est ce que disait
celui qui va laisser sa place on
évoquait justement son avenir au début
de cette émission jean françois legrand
que ce département devienne une réserve
d'indiens pour reprendre ses propos je
pense qu'il ya longtemps qu'ils habitent
il a fait évoluer son discours puisque
jean-françois ne se pose pas à cette
normandie réunifiée
ce qu'il a dit ça on ne l'a pas dit
qu'il était peut-être c'est une
caricature comme moi je ne suis pas tout
à l'heure de la pièce jamais des ventes
à la grande région
chacun veut qu'elle marche et elle a la
taille de la région
c'est pas suffisant j'avoue c'est un
projet de la région voir ce que ça
signifie c'est que sur les 25 dernières
années il ya eu des restructurations
dans l'industrie notamment qui ont été
des restructurations qui était voulu par
les politiques européennes ça c'est une
réalité
donc la manche est un département qui a
vocation à être touristique et qu'il
l'est déjà mais c'est un département qui
est industriel et il faut pouvoir
préserver ces outils industriels pour ne
pas devenir une réserve d'indiens en
effet alors préserver ces outils
industriels préserver également un
département et une image que ce
département s'est forgé on va y venir
justement plus de 300 km de côtes je
rappeler comment tirer profit de cette
façade maritime tout en respectant
l'environnement aussi en 7 et jean les
populations face à des phénomènes comme
xynthia
il ya une pression forte sur le littoral
qu'on avait relevé au cours des 40
dernières années avec certains secteurs
qui se sont énormément développés je
pense à certaines communes du sud
notamment au sud de granville est ce que
l'on doit limiter est-ce que vous aurez
le pouvoir si vous êtes à la tête du
département de la manche demain de
limiter les constructions et la
bétonisation de la côte
philippe bas est ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous ferez je partage pas du
tout votre analyse
il y a quelques points où effectivement
l'urbanisation liés aux résidences
secondaires s'est développée mais il ya
surtout dans notre département un
problème d'application au monde rural de
la loi littoral qui entravent des
projets de développement qui ne mettrait
pas en péril le respect de
l'environnement et
nous travaillons très activement à une
meilleure prise en compte de cette
spécificité le littoral rural il faut
construire un peu plus à certains
endroits sur le littoral c'est ça la
position souple et faut faire en sorte
que quand il y a cinq maisons et un
terrain au milieu on puisse construire
sur ce terrain il ne faut pas créer de
nouvelles zones d'urbanisation
il faut faire en sorte qu' il n'y ait
pas cette rigidité d'ailleurs qu'il
n'était pas dans la loi littoral que
tout le monde veut préserver mais cette
rigidité qui est liée à la
multiplication des contentieux et qui
font qu'aujourd'hui on applique la loi
littoral au dans la manche comme sur la
côte d'azur alors que les enjeux ne sont
pas les mêmes et nous avons voulu dans
la loi sur la réforme territoriale
donner aux régions et aux élus un
pouvoir d'interprétation de la loi
littoral sous le contrôle du conseil
national du bit alors à quoi ressemblera
le département de la manche justement
dans les quinze ou vingt prochaines
années
question de sébastien berlier les élus
locaux du littoral de la manche quand
ils vous demandent de vraies en tant que
parlementaire pour assouplir la loi
littoral eux c'est parce qu'ils veulent
construire beaucoup plus clairement
ils ne veulent pas qu'on interdise tout
temps de construire s'est pas exactement
la vision des projets ils ont des
projets de lotissements dans certaines
communes on y veille
c'est clair telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui la loi littoral sont ce
décret d'application qui n'ont jamais
été publiés c'est là que le bât blesse
dans sept ou à littoral
c'est une insécurité juridique
permanente pour les mères puisque tous
les recours sont possibles et ils sont
tranchées à chaque fois en défaveur des
projets des communes
je pense qu'il ya besoin d'un
assouplissement de la loi littoral c'est
le travail de que fait notre collègue
bizet avec des thériault la sénatrice ps
qui ont remis un rapport sénatorial sur
le sujet pour assouplir la loi littoral
comme a été assouplie ne s'agit pas de
casser la 8c loi littoral mais de lui
donner plus de souplesse
quel département les habitants auront
dans les quinze ou vingt prochaines
années à quoi ressemblera ce département
le moins que voulez vous en faire vous
parlait de l'assouplissement de la loi
littoral
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on
permet à des hameaux de devenir des
débours et finalement des communes pas
du tout fallu si je peux écrire ça bon
c'est vrai que moi j'ai rencontré de
nombreux maires sur le sujet aujourd'hui
n'ose plus prendre de décisions
ils ont dans un mot une friche qui est
là et qui lit au milieu d'un hameau et
ou ne peuvent pas accomplir parce
qu'aujourd'hui la loi littoral ne permet
pas de le faire donc c'est vraiment une
insécurité juridique permanente pour les
mères il faut assouplir et on veut
préserver notre littoral on ne peut pas
la détruire cette fois a dit on essaye
dc100 la joie du syndic ceux qui ont
commenté les évènements de la tempête
xynthia parle d'insécurité des
populations jean jacques noël est ce que
demain justement on assouplit la loi
littoral contenu des risques qui
demandent des sceaux m en parlant
derrière lui dire
un possible accord avec la soupe israël
qui a été cité d'un terrain au milieu de
deux parcelles déjà construite c'est ça
il faut permettre c'est assez devenir
constructibles ça ne veut pas dire qu'on
va étendre les hameaux à l'infini sa non
on est bien d'accord que l'on va pas se
se projeter dans ce schéma là ce qu'il
faut admettre aussi c'est que les gens
viennent dans la manche
les touristes viennent dans la manche
parce que justement la cote n'est pas
bétonné comme dans certains coins les
gens viennent aussi pour l'aspect
naturel du département donc assouplir la
loi littoral ça veut dire voilà libéré
quelques parcelles au sein d d d d un
mot déjà construit n'est pas forcément
un bétonnage complet et puis autre chose
il va falloir aussi renforcer la
protection du littoral
voilà je pense notamment aux habitants
de la région de denneville qui subissent
les assauts des tempêtes successives il
faut il faut il va falloir renforcer
aussi la protection du littoral leur
permettent l'enrochement permettre des
travaux pour protéger l'habitat déjà
existant sur la question de décines mois
la branche dommages non l'enclin en
battant ça ressemblera à quoi ce
département oui la manche ce sont les
hommes et les femmes qui y vivent et on
sait qu'il ya un vieillissement qui est
important notamment donc tout ce que
sont les compétences du conseil général
c'est aussi cette question des personnes
âgées donc il ya des projets qui seront
portés dans le cadre de ces élections
départementales le enfin l'une des
propositions comporte là où on est en
tant qu'élu c'est le pôle public
c'est l'atelier public pardon un atelier
publiques d'urbanisme qui permet d'avoir
des regards croisés sur les aménagements
qui se font donc l'assouplissement de la
loi du littoral mois a priori je suis
pas favorable et je connais mal le sujet
mais en terme d'aménagement urbain ou
d'aménagement sûr mais même dans les
communes rurales
il faudrait créer un outil qui permette
à des architectes conseils à des élus à
des fonctionnaires à des citoyens de
donner leur avis on va prendre un
exemple justement qui rejoint la gestion
du littoral c'est le cas de vous l'avez
certainement lu dans
réponse ou entendu sur les antennes de
france bleu ou france 3 c'est le cas de
cette bergerie dans la vidéo ça michel
cette dernière bergerie de mouton aoc
qui est pour l'instant condamné à être
détruites par deux décisions de justice
il y à un appel devant le conseil d'état
qu'est ce qu'on fait là justement est-ce
qu'on permet à à cet exploitant de
rester ou est-ce qu'on se bat pour qui
le maintien d'une activité ou est ce que
l'on se conformer aux lois
environnementales il respecte justement
de la bande littorale rapidement les uns
les autres visuels et des moutons dans
la baie du mont-saint-michel y en a
depuis le moyen-âge mais à l'époque les
bergers pouvait avoir cinq moutons
aujourd'hui si vous voulez vivre de vos
moutons il en faut plusieurs centaines
il faut donc des bergeries et cette
bergerie elle est impeccable
elle est complètement isolé invisible de
tout point de promenade dans la baie du
mont saint michel
elle a été autorisée par arrêté il y a
eu des contestations je crois qu'il faut
arrêter les procès et faire triompher le
bon sens ou bien on veut des moutons qui
mangent les herbus est alors à ce
moment-là l'écosystème de la baie tel
qu'il existe depuis le moyen-âge sera
préservé ou bien ne veut pas de
bergeries on aura plus de moutons et les
herbus ne seront plus traitées de
manière écologique d'accord opposèrent
l'écologie l'environnement jusqu'à
certaines conditions la presse qu'on
comprend c'est un débat qui est très
actuelle au regard de ce qui s'est passé
il ya quelques semaines sur le barrage
aussi 20 soit alors à notre dame des
landes pire billet sur cette question
justement tu as tout à fait ce que vient
de dire fibre est d'accord pour que
d'accord je veux dire que c'est vers
l'est en se
ce berger mâle chaîne son exploit des
améliorations de la région puissent
former d'alors de la loi littoral c'est
ça en fait on est en plein dans les uns
les autres
rapidement il reste sur mon principe
avec cette schizophrénie le système
français où on oblige ce berger avoir
une une bergerie sur le à proximité des
herbus pour être dans la op justement
c'est là qu'est toute la subtilité de la
chose on ne devrait pas opposées
économie et écologie
d'où notre section tout à l'heure c'est
cette révision de la loi littoral est
nécessaire et le département devrait
avoir compétence pour intervenir dans ce
genre de litige
voilà ce berger est victime de
d'ayatollahs de l'écologie et savoureuse
et adorait france ceci dit aujourd'hui
il ya eu une décision judiciaire
est ce qu'il faut détruire cette
bergerie très concrètement et qu'est ce
qu'on fait après on la construit un peu
un peu plus loin et on tuera le dernier
dernier producteur de dany aux prés
salés
non non vous d'aller au bout d'une
basse-cour juridique et je pense que là
encore avec un peu de dialogue de
concertation y compris d'ailleurs avec
des associations de protection de
l'environnement qui comprennent bien que
la présence d'une bergerie est
nécessaire à la présence des moutons qui
sont nécessaires à l'écologie de la baie
du mont saint michel et on ne peut pas
sortir de là on va finir par y arriver
tout de même on est dans la bo est resté
on a commencé cette émission dans le
nord cotentin en parlant de l'usiné
areva de la hague
le premier tour des élections
départementales c'est le 22 mars c'est
un week-end de grandes marées c'est même
la première marais du siècle
le samedi 21 est-ce que vous irez pêcher
les voies du côté de la baie
la veille du premier tour sourire non ce
sera un clin d'oeil par rapport à la
grande barre et je pense que mon père il
pèsera la seule ce jour là pierre weill
et non je pense oui une grande marée ça
n'empêche pas d'aller voter les grandes
marées mais à la pêche on ira tous à la
pêche qui aime ça mais il faudra penser
aussi à la beauté parce que c'est
important d'aller voter à ce scrutin n'a
peut-être plus qu'un autre sur la
vocation du mont saint michel à être une
vitrine de la basse normandie
ça sera une année importante 2015 avec
le rétablissement maritime qui va se
confirmer avec la destruction de la
digue route philippe bas il faut
s'appuyer sur le mont saint michel
oui une vitrine sans la vitrification
avec de la vie quand même comme il y en
a toujours eu mais notre département il
est magnifique et nous avons des joyaux
et nous devons nous organiser pour le
tourisme le tourisme rural comme le
tourisme autour de notre grande
destination touristique de nos grandes
destinations touristiques
jean jacques noël juste un mot pour
conclure il nous reste quelques secondes
le mot de la fin mais écoutez je pense
que je serai un bon candidat je
défendrai mon département et dont le
strict intérêt d des manchots et des
manchois à l'e3 trois gorges et trois
secondes les uns et les autres auront
lieu faire une conclusion il est bas sur
et ne sommes plus aujourd'hui il faut
qu'on se rassemble le plus largement
possible pour qu'il ya une manche
nouvelles avec des énergies nouvelles
pour le service de la population
pierre billets et à l'hôtel le 22 mars
il faut que les manchois se saisissent
de leur département en allant de théâtre
la terre ou des centres de santé
municipaux parce que c'est un des échecs
que du conseil général sortant
très bien merci à tous les cadres
d'avoir participé à ce débat merci à
christian desrosiers de ouest-france et
sébastien barrio de france bleu cotentin
merci je dis nous avons accompagné bon
week-end et à la semaine prochaine pour
un débat sur le département de l'orne